i definitely don't think i would feel
incomplete if i didn't have more but
another one would just add
more love to the house and now that baby
number two's arrived khloe kardashian's
got a house full of love it's a
beautiful thing the source tells et coco
and her ex tristan thompson are excited
about the newest member of their family
the former couple who is already proud
parents to four-year-old daughter true
recently welcomed their second child
together a baby boy via surrogate our
source says coco has been with the baby
for a little while now and is adjusting
to being a mom of two that's the only
thing was i just like
born to believe i need to have so many
kids i don't know the source adds chloe
is so grateful to have been able to
expand her family and as for tristan
he's enjoying the little bundle of joy
too he really wanted a baby boy and is
so happy to have welcomed a son it's
just easy to co-parent with him so how's
true adjusting to her big sis promotion
well our source says that she's so
thrilled to have a baby brother she is
loving every moment about being a big
sister and wants to be a mini mommy to
the baby i am so obsessed with her and i
love it so much and now that coco's got
her hands full with two kiddos many are
wondering if she's got time for romance
if we rewind back to december chloe and
tristan called it quits after news broke
of his latest cheating scandal where he
fathered a child with another woman i'm
not sure that there's one thing that
hurts more than the other in a situation
like this everything is
an act of betrayal everything is a lie
everything is
manipulation it's deceit in july another
source explained to et when they were on
good terms they decided to move forward
with surrogacy near the end of last year
and then tristan was caught cheating and
since then the two haven't spoken
outside of co-parenting matters i think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but chloe's moved on and she's
dating that's the goal is finding
someone to do nothing back in june a
source told et she was dating a private
equity investor they met through her
sister kim i love that but now another
source confirms things fizzled out a few
weeks ago it was never very serious to
begin with her family was aware that it
wasn't serious and didn't think much of
it but support chloe getting back out
there and dating again tristan was
respectful about chloe dating again as
well but knows it is also complicated
i'm gonna figure it all out i promise
you